well this is a great place to end Daniel
you're now speaking directly to the
people well you have been this whole
time but even more so now to the people
who have been watching and listening
what's something you want to leave them
with what should they do they're here
they've heard all these issues they hear
about me and they're like okay that
sounds cool that's motivating it's a bit
abstract but it is motivated okay what
should I do Daniel
I want the Earth to be here in decades
from now centuries from now what should
I do
laughs
so I'm going to answer this in a way
that I think factors who your audience
probably is I just I don't know we had
even shared demographics with me but um
based on the attractor I can guess
um
if I was answering just to a series of
technologists or investors or
bureaucrats I might say something
different
um and realizing that amongst that
audience there are people who are going
to have
radically different skills and
capacities and parts of it that they
feel the most motivated and oriented to
so I'm obviously not going to say one
thing everybody should do
um
okay what I'll say is
whether it's hearing a conversation like
this where the planetary boundaries and
really thinking about that there's more
biomass of animals and factory farms
than there are in the wild left of the
total amount of species Extinction or
the what the risks associated with
the rapid development of decentralizing
synthetic biology and air you hear these
things you're like and it connects
you to
what is most important beyond your own
narrow life or even the politics that is
coming into your stream or whether it's
when you
have a deep meditation or a medicine
Journey or whatever it is and connect to
what is most meaningful design your life
in a way where that experience happens
regularly
so what you are
paying attention to and optimizing for
on a daily basis is connected to the
deepest values you have
because on a daily basis the people
around you and your job and your news
feed are probably sharing other things
so try to configure it that the
the
deepest true good and beautiful that
you're aware of is continuously in your
awareness so your daily choices of how
you spend your time and money is
continuously at least informed by that
that's the first thing I would say I
would say a couple other things
aligned with that is
look at things that are happening in the
world online
to have a sense of things that you can't
see in front of you but then also get
offline
and
connect with both the
trees in front of you now without any
modeling or value system just how
innately beautiful they are
and also
the mirror neuron experience when you're
with a homeless person right like so
both have an EXT a sense of what's
happening at scale but then also ground
and embodied sense your own care for the
real world that is not just on a
computer there's a real world here
and then realize like deepen
actually matters
like independent of whether I can
formalize a particular
meaning or purpose of the universe
argument or formalize a response to
solipsistic arguments or nihilistic
arguments like prima facie reality
is Meaningful
and I actually do care I wouldn't get
sad or upset or inspired or improved if
I didn't care about anything
I actually do care
and so life matters and I make choices
and I can make choices that affect the
world so my own choices matter so what
choices am I making every moment and
what is the basis that I want to guide
them by right to just deepen the sense
of the meaningfulness of life in your
own choice
and this and the seriousness with which
you take how you design your life
um particularly facting factoring the
timeliness and evidence of the issues
that we Face currently
and then the last thing I would say is
as you could like really work to get
more educated about the issues that you
care about and are concerned about
really work to get more educated about
them get more connected to the people
working on them
and really study
the
views that are counter to the Views that
naturally appeal to you
so you bias correct so that your own
well-motivated biases don't mess up your
action
and in doing that don't let yourself
become an agendic don't let yourself
become so overwhelmed don't let yourself
fall into easy certainties
but also don't let yourself be
overwhelmed by the total uncertainty
that you can't act realizing that if you
don't act
there are ethical consequences to that
too because we're on a moving train
thank you Daniel I appreciate you
spending almost four hours now with me
[Music]
likewise uh
we covered a bunch of areas that I did
not expect but they're all good areas
I'm curious how thing ends up getting uh
edited and makes it through and I'm also
curious with your particularly
philosophically interested in insightful
audience what questions and thoughts
emerge in this and maybe we'll get to
address some of them someday yeah
there's definitely going to be a part
too cool a much more philosophical part
too if this one wasn't already you just
watched a clip from the theories of
everything channel for the full video
and all its magnificence then click here
and if you'd like to see more then
subscribe enjoy